hey guys Ryan right here and tonight I'm
gonna be watching movie clips again
everyone's telling me to watch these two
new spider-man clips before we know it
the whole movie will be released on the
internet and everyone is gonna be pissed
off but that's what you all are asking
for pretty much normally I don't watch
movie clips but a lot of people keep
telling me to watch them solemnly
alright I'm gonna check these out I know
it's gonna be awesome I know it's gonna
rock it's [ __ ] spider-man okay it's
gonna be cool like the first amazing
spider-man Rock sock and possum I'd have
sex with that movie this one I'd have an
orgy with it like we can already tell
from the trailers and the few clips that
it's probably gonna be better than the
last one
this might in fact be the biggest
spider-man yet oh it's that spider-man
could be extended comedian I just
imagine him going out on the stage with
a suit on so today I was surfing the web
haha can't really think of any more
spider puns yeah okay so this first clip
that I'm gonna watch is the one that not
everyone's really talking too much about
but the other one is like the amped up
one this one's called skipping rocks I
really don't know what this Clips about
but let's find out
I guess that kind of oh yeah ain't gotta
explain anything to me man both got
dumped
what you ever see your well oh that kind
of dumped my dad left a briefcase so I
got briefcase full of junk no briefcase
full of junk
how's that working out
buddy I want to experience that scene in
IMAX 3d okay okay that was a good
warm-up scene the you know bond isn't
like how James Franco and Tobey Maguire
did it a Harry Peter what's up I kind of
like the distance barrier thing that was
created between them and now it's a
friendship rekindling I I think that's
gonna be awesome way to go
Marc Webb here we go
amazing spider-man 2 this is the one
this is the one everyone's talking about
neighborhood ornament
don't know what it's about everyone has
told me it is awesome
that Captain America shield
on the side
it looks a little fake
it's still pretty cool
everything's gonna be okay guys that is
not how spider-man dies
yeah the clips that they're releasing
are very smart that they're all given a
different tone you know like the electro
one was really like a villainous type of
thing and then you got the gwen stacy
one it's romantic then you got the like
dramatic friendship kind of indie feel
thing going on with Harry Osborne in
Peter Parker then you got this fun
little whimsical adventurous side so
yeah all these clips are awesome just
makes you want to watch the movie more
when the [ __ ] or the tickets gonna go on
presale anyway guys thanks for
suggesting that one to me I really liked
it a lot you know if you want to suggest
more you can comment below and if you're
new boy I am that button tells you to
stop scribe I feel like dancing and
wanna dance another way this movie just
is really exciting I'm excited to see it